翻訳: Kumika Moore
校正: Hiroko Kawano
「国際文化アナリスト」って
聞いたことある人 います？
あれ ああ
僕の家族じゃないですか
（笑）
基本的には いないと思います
なぜかというと 僕が勝手に作ったからです
（笑）
なぜかといいますと
僕がいろんな社会活動をしようと思った時に
自分のやりたい事と その既存の
すでにある肩書きっていうものが
マッチするものが ありませんでした
だったら 自分で作ったらいいだろう と
例えば 世の中では
「なんとかメディアクリエーター」
とかありますよね？
（笑）
そんな感じで言い続けてれば
そのうち定着するんじゃないかと思ってます
本日は実は 幸せについての
話をしたいと思います
なぜ幸せの話かといいますと
実は 幸福の研究には大きく分けて
３つのカテゴリーがあります
１つ目は 脳科学とか心理学の話ですね
これは一番 主流の話で
皆さんが よくご存じかもしれません
そして もう１つは
「昔はよかった系」ですね
（笑）
これ意外と根拠が なかったりするんですよ
実際にデータが なかったりとか
幸せの話となると よく出てくるブータン
実はここです
持続可能性のことだったりとか
普遍性っていう意味で
ちょっと疑問が残ります
そしてじゃあ３つ目
何かというと
文化、社会環境の影響が
どのように人々の幸福に
インパクトを与えているかっていう
研究なんですが
これ ほとんどされてないです
だから本日は 国際文化アナリストとして
僕が実際の そのいろんなデータを
分析しながら解説したいと思います
実は 僕は以前
金融トレーダーという―
外資系の アメリカの証券会社で
仕事をしていました
これは お金からどうやってお金を生むか
という非常にシビアな世界だったんですが
そんな ―
ある程度 収入的には そんなに
悪くなかったんですけれども
でも 僕は幸せじゃありませんでした
じゃあ どうすればいいか？
他に自分が何をすればいいかって
考えたんですけども
でも何をしたらいいか
ほんと わかりませんでした
だったら じゃあ基本的に もう自分自身の
その発想を根底から覆すような
いわゆるパラダイムの変換みたいなもの
これが必要なんじゃないかと思いました
じゃあ どうしたら
パラダイムの変換ができるかというと
自分自身を知らない文化の所に
そのまま入れてしまう
それによって
見たことも聞いたこともないような
人生観が最初から ひっくり返るような
そんな経験をする必要が
あるんじゃないかと思って
僕は もう会社 辞めました
そして自らの環境を変えて 旅に出ました
最初は２、３年で世界を旅する
つもりだったんですけども
気がついたら 10年経ってました
本当は この旅の話
たくさん面白いのあるんですけども
本日 ちょっと時間がないので
ここで割愛させていただきます
もしTEDx とかが２時間ぐらい
話 させてくれるんだったら
（笑）
その時 また呼んでください
その旅を通じて一つ大きく
気がついたことがあります
それは「人を幸せにしやすい社会」
そして「人を幸せにしにくい社会」
というのがあるっていうことに気がつきました
具体的にどういうことかというと
まず じゃあ自殺率ですね
日本の自殺率っていうのは 世界でも
第７番目ぐらいで かなり高いです
ただ この自殺率の その統計を見てみると
上位30カ国中の20カ国が
実は 旧共産主義とアジア
これに独占されてます
そうしますと じゃあ１つ疑問が出てきました
そもそも 社会っていうのは
何のためにあるのか？
この１つの簡単な答えがあります
個人の幸せのため
だって その社会を構成している
その一人一人が幸せにならなかったら
じゃあ一体 社会が何のためにあるのか
意味わかんないですよね？
じゃあ日本の幸福度 みてみましょう
外面からみた日本の幸福度
「外面」っていうのは
これ どういうことかというと
こういう条件を揃えると
人が幸せになるだろうっていうことを
客観的にインデックス化したデータです
平均寿命であったりとか 一人当たりGDP
識字率とか そういう条件ですね
これを見ると 日本の幸福度って
意外と高いんですよ
世界でも結構トップレベルです
だから 結構 日本人の皆さんが
「いやぁ 日本っていうのは
すごく幸せな国だよ」って言うのは
ある程度 根拠があるんじゃないか
こういう所から
来てるんじゃないかと思うんですが
ただ １つ大きな まだ疑問が残ります
何かというと
「そもそも幸せっていうのは
誰が決めてるんですか？」
もし他人が
「いや あなた こうなったら幸せだ」
ということをいくら言ってもですね
自分自身が その幸せを感じてなかったら
それ 全く意味ないですよね？
じゃあ 日本人の
こういった内面からみた
どういう風に幸せと感じているか
これを見てみると意外と低いんですよ
世界の中でも大体 真ん中ぐらい
そして先進国の中では これは ほぼ最低です
ちなみに 1958年から
日本の一人当たりGDPっていうのは
約６倍に上がりました
でも その間の「生活満足度」ですね
「幸福度」っていうふうにも
言えるかもしれないんですが
これは横ばいです
この間 例えば
1980年代後半のバブルの絶頂期
日本のその経済が 世界を圧巻して
失業率１％ですよ
今も 言われているような社会問題
一切ありませんでした
そんな時でさえ 生活満足度
変わってなかったということです
こういう話をすると
「いや それは 日本人って
なんかDNAが違うんだ」とか
なんか「遺伝の問題だ」とかね
こういうことを考える方が
いらっしゃるかもしれないんで
ここで１つ 非常に面白い例を出します
旧東ドイツと旧西ドイツ
この２つの国は 1990年に
ベルリンの壁が崩壊するまで45年間
１つは共産主義 １つは資本主義っていう
全く違うシステムの中で
１つの壮大な 社会実験が行われました
この２つの国っていうのは
民族も言語も全く同じですよね？
でも ベルリンの壁が崩壊した後
旧共産主義の東ドイツっていうのが
一貫して幸福度が低い
これは 社会システムが どれほど
人々の幸福度に影響を与えるかという
非常にいい例だと思います
この次が 主観的幸福度 ― 幸福感と
一人当たりGDPを比べたものなんですが
赤い所が ラテンアメリカ
そして青い所が 旧共産主義国です
ちょっと見にくいかもしれないんですけども
簡単に言うと
ラテンアメリカと旧共産主義国っていうのは
経済的な規模では ほぼ一緒です
でも幸福度で見ると
ラテンアメリカの人たちっていうのは
もう圧倒的に幸福度が高いです
僕も実は２年ほど
アルゼンチンとかに いたんですけども
間違いないです
非常に幸福度が高いです
今でも行きたいぐらいです
ちなみに日本は GDP 高い割には
幸福度は結構低いです
結局 人種
これは幸福度には関係ないです
気候
関係ないです
よく あったかい所にいる人たちってのは
なんか すごいハッピーじゃないかと
思われる方も いるかもしれないですけども
実際に統計を見ると まったく関係ないです
宗教
関係ないです
じゃあ どんな環境が
人を幸せにするんでしょうか？
あります
自ら選べる範囲が広い
つまり自己決定権が広い
そういう地域が
幸福度が高いということですね
じゃあ 自己決定権
どういうことか？
自分の属性に関係なく
人生を選べることができるか？
これは１つの例なんですけども
男女平等指数ですね
例えば その人が
男であるとか 女であるとか
そういうことによって
人生が決められてしまうのか
日本は残念ながら
世界142か国中 104位です
非常に 男女平等指数 悪いですね
これは言い換えると
「社会の寛容度」っていう言い方もできます
じゃあ この寛容度
これを どうやったら調べられるか
実は１つ 非常にわかりやすい
指標があるんですよ
これ何かというと
どこの社会にも必ず存在するマイノリティ
少数派の人たちが その社会で
どういった市民権を得ているか
これを見てみると わかるんですね
この地図は 世界の
同性愛の結婚が認められている所
青い所が認められている所
そして茶色いオレンジの所がですね
同性愛であることが
違法であって 最悪 死刑になる地域です
なぜ同性愛の話かというと
あなた自身が 同性愛者であるか
どうかっていうのは
それは 他人は一切 決定できません
あなたが自分で そう感じるかどうか
それだけですよね？
ということは その感じるという
自分の その意思によって
その意思を どれだけその社会が
リスペクトして ちゃんと守ってくれるか
こういう寛容度が高いということなんです
だから 同性愛の結婚が
合法化されている所っていうのは
軒並み幸福度が高いです
これは集団主義の
構造的な問題なんですね
どういうことかというと
そもそも集団主義というのは
これは
「みんなと同じことをしてください」
これが集団主義ですね
ただ じゃあ幸せって何かとなると
やっぱりこれは 人それぞれ
自分が決めなきゃいけない と
ということはですね
じゃあ集団主義である限りは
幸せっていうのは
どっかで頭打ちになっちゃうんですよ
例えば 日本人に「休みが欲しいですか？」
という話を聞いたとすると
それは当然みんな「そうです」
と言うでしょう
でも じゃあ「実際 休み取りましたか？」
と言うと みんな「取ってません」 と
日本人の有給休暇 消化率
これは世界最低レベルです
じゃあ「なんで休まないんですか？」と言うと
「いや 他の誰も休み取らないんで」
と言うんですね
だから 個人がやりたくない
ことであったとしても
みんながやるから
だから それをやらなきゃいけないっていう
ちょっと非常に危険な
臭いがする環境ですよね？
その行き着く果てが過労死ですよ
つまり 生きるために働くはずが
働き過ぎて死んでしまう
非常に本末転倒な結果になってしまう
ただですね
じゃあ その集団主義が諸悪の根源か
というと実は そうではないんですよ
なぜかっていうと 人類っていうのは
集団主義から始まったからです
だから 問題としては
集団主義とかいうことじゃなくて
これは 文化を完全に超越した
歴史的な必然なんですね
例えば 「思いやり」とか「絆」、「協力」
こういう言葉は 特に震災後
非常に言われました
「日本人の特質だ」みたいな話は
よく出てくるんですが
違います
人類共通です
思いやりとか どこの国でも
どの社会でも必ずあります
だから これは社会として
取り組んできた大きな課題として
個人を追求すること
そして集団とどうやって折り合いをつけるか
ここが問題なんですよね
歴史的な その流れを見ると
「個」っていうものが より自由に動いている
こういうプロセスが見えてきます
民主主義
これは典型的な例ですよね？
そして 共産主義
これは究極の集団主義です
そしてインターネットやオープンソース
こういったものっていうのは つまり社会から
個人の方に決定権が移されている と
もう１つ ポイントは
逆には戻れないっていうことですよね
そうは言っても その集団に属したり
人に認められるっていうことは
これは幸せを感じる大きな要因でもあります
ただ 集団に自分自身を
同化させるっていうことで
その集団に承認されるっていうことが
結局は 自己を最終的には
否定することになって
中途半端な満足 ―
中途半端ですね
それしか達成されない
集団主義の前提っていうのは要するに
みんながみんな同じことをやりなさい と
でも同じことをやると ―
「同じことをやらないと社会がバラバラに
なっちゃうから」っていうふうに言われますね
つまり どういうことかというと
個人の能力をある意味 否定してるんですよ
でも これは嘘です
完全に洗脳ですね
実際 個人の幸福追求っていうものと
そして 社会の利益
これは矛盾しません
例えば人権の問題とか教育問題
経済の問題
あとは 地方分権とかね
いろんな今 社会問題
取り沙汰されているものがあるんですけれども
こういった問題っていうのは ある意味
自己決定権を拡大していくっていう
こういった同じテーマで見ることができます
ただ こういった例えば
その人権の男女平等ね
「なんで男女平等を
しなきゃいけないんですか？」
「なんで少数派の人権
守んなきゃいけないんですか？」
教育で個人の可能性を
最大化しなきゃいけない
「何のためですか？」
起業家精神
「何のためにそんなこと
しなきゃいけないんだ？」
地方分権
「何なんですか？」
これの答えが 実は幸福の追求です
これが全く「幸せのためにあるんだ」っていう
みんなが同じ目線で 同じゴールを持って
社会問題を解決することが可能なんです
最後に皆さんに質問したいと思います
あなたは 何のために生きてるのですか？
この質問に対して 即答で
「いや 幸せのためだ」
こう答えることができたら
そこでやっと出発点に立つことができます
なぜかというと そこで初めて
「じゃあ どうしたら幸せになるか」っていう
ことを考えることができるからです
そして その社会を構成してる一人一人が
「幸せのために生きてるんだ」っていうふうに
考えていくことができるんだったら
そこで初めて
「じゃあ その社会が何のためにあるんだ」
「幸せのためにあるんですよね」っていう
コンセンサスが 取れるんじゃないでしょうか
以上です
（拍手）
ありがとうございました